good morning Hank it's Sunday November
22nd and today we will be discussing the
burgeoning Marxist revolution in the
West African nation of Benin are the new
viewers gone yet no Hank today we aren't
going to be discussing the burgeoning
Marxist revolution in Benin partly
because I made it up we're gonna talk
about something much more exciting your
pain yes Hank today November 22nd is a
day that will live in funny what funny
it's like the opposite of infamy it's
like there's days that will live in
infamy
and then there's days that will live in
funny Hank I think I can speak for all
of nerdfighteria when I say we have been
waiting to punish you forever all we
want to do is for suffering and
humiliation upon you but every single
Wednesday you make a video every other
Wednesday it's a song every other
Tuesday you make a video they're never
more than four minutes long it's
incredibly annoying and then when you do
break the rules like when you briefly
uploaded a seven-minute version of your
severed hands of Star Wars video you
call me and insist that while you may
have broken the letter of the law you
didn't break the spirit of the law and
so of course after you posted a four
minute into second video last week you
called me and you're like it was only
the subscription Scrolls Hank I'm
sympathetic to your plight but let me
tell you a story about a world with no
rules
Hank once upon a time there was an
extremely important and closely fought
soccer match and then toward the end of
that soccer match Thierry Ari caught a
ball put it on his feet kicked it to his
friend who then scored a goal and France
gets to go to the World Cup because they
cheated that's what happens in a world
where you don't enforce the rules and
while I might have to live with that
stupid kind of stuff in real life I will
not stand for it in nerdfighteria sorry
I'm still kind of mad about that
handball oh hey here's what bothers me
about Thierry anri's flagrant handball
in a game that you probably haven't
heard of and don't care about human
beings have this tendency in sports and
also in real life to think that breaking
the rules is not really breaking the
rules unless and until you get caught
maybe the giant squids of anger should
have a head just be like blah
all of which is to say Hank that you are
getting punished huzzah
ah boy am I excited I don't even mind
that I'm getting punished when you're
also getting punished nerdfighters you
know as well as I do that we do not
often get a chance to punish Hank so
let's not mess this up I need your
excellent punishment suggestions and
comments and if you have time I'd love
it if you read through all the comments
with me and thumbs up the ones that you
liked the most
oh boy Hank I have a great feeling about
this punishment I think it's just gonna
be one of the funniest to date
nerdfighters dftba Hank I'll see you on
Tuesday
my beard has become very beardy but no
matter how beardy it gets in here
there's still kind of a fundamental
inability to beard over in this area